sí
ya debes tener un buen manejo de la
relación entre la posición la velocidad
y la aceleración antes de que
desarrollemos fórmulas para explicar
cómo se moverán las partículas con base
en las leyes de la física es necesario
que repasemos nuestra manera de pensar
acerca de la velocidad de una partícula
necesitamos conocer no sólo qué tan
rápido se mueve sino también la
dirección en la que se mueve en este
caso es hacia abajo para representar
cosas que tienen tamaño y dirección
usamos un concepto llamado vector los
vectores se dibujan como flechas la
dirección es hacia dónde está apuntando
y la longitud de la flecha llamada
magnitud del vector indica su tamaño
llamamos a este punto la cola del vector
ya este otro la cabeza del vector usamos
un vector llamado velocidad para
describir la velocidad y la dirección de
la partícula un vector corto indica que
la partícula se mueve lentamente
indica que la partícula se mueve
rápidamente en este diagrama el
movimiento de la pelota es descendente
por lo que el vector velocidad apunta
hacia abajo si la partícula acelera por
ejemplo debido a la gravedad entonces la
longitud del vector velocidad aumentará
con el tiempo debido a que la velocidad
está aumentando la aceleración también
es un vector ya que tiene magnitud y
dirección pero observa que el tamaño del
vector aceleración no cambia mientras la
pelota cae
como vimos en el vídeo anterior una
partícula que cae bajo la influencia de
la gravedad tiene una aceleración
constante eso quiere decir que tanto la
dirección como el tamaño del vector
aceleración son constantes como se
muestra aquí
también es necesario que sumemos
vectores lo hacemos mediante el uso del
método de cabeza a cola por ejemplo si
necesitamos sumar dos vectores b&w
movemos el vector w
de manera que la cabeza detector b está
en la cola del vector w como en este
ejemplo y el vector resultante que sería
b más w va desde la cola de p hasta la
cabeza de w
bien ya tenemos muchos conceptos nuevos
así que hagamos una pausa aquí para que
practiques con ellos en el siguiente
ejercicio no podemos hacer nuestras
películas sin vectores cada vez que ves
alguna cosa que se mueve dentro de
nuestras películas estamos usando
vectores